i think what they're doing right now is
getting us super acquainted to understanding
the rules and the definitions that way when
the rules are being broken we understand the
stakes and we could follow what the hell is
going on in this movie because because of the
fact of how crazy all this is going to be this
is all gonna be nuts and it is all gonna be
connected and i think it's already connected
they're just not making it as obvious because
it's not as simple i'm here to defend marvel
what's going on there reject nation greg and john
here today what we're going to talk about today
might seem pointless to some yet uh i i don't
think it is pointless especially when i go
online and i i see this being kind of a common
complaint for some this may be already like an
obvious answer for others i i guess i'll i'll
try to offer up a glimmer of hope if that's what
you're looking for i don't really know what we're
talking about today is is marvel's phase four
has it been directionless i am often hearing that
some people are feeling about marvel phase four it
makes sense to me why some people might actually
feel that way yet i don't actually agree with
it being directionless i think there's kind of a
fascinating point that we don't know where exactly
the mcu is headed we have our ideas of where it
could be going based off comics and such and a
bunch of clues that have been given from the shows
and movies but i wouldn't call it directionless so
before we hop into this if you guys can leave a
like that'd be very much appreciated all right
so looking through marvel phase four there's
been a lot that has been introduced you know
like starting with one division start getting
a lot more sorcery abilities and a lot more
supernatural elements with things like moon knight
and then you have things that seem like they might
be the biggest game changers for the mcu hands
down you know you had like loki and then the
timelines breaking apart with uh he who remains
at the very end of it he had the multiverse
with spider-man no way home and then you had dr
strange and the multiverse of madness and i think
as viewers what we're so used to with marvel for
the infinity saga is things just feeling you know
very connected in a very obvious way phase one
through three which i find funny when you think
about it because the whole thing was leading up to
the fight with thanos getting the infinity stones
it's something really easy to like wrap your head
around it's really like physical really clear
through a line that we're building up to a big
baddie by the end of it and we know who the
big baddie is but what's funny to me is how joss
whedon just threw that thanos cameo in there just
for fun and didn't had no intention of it like
building into what it became but that's what it is
and i feel like that's really set our expectations
for the marvel cinematic universe going forward
so with this one i can actually see why people
feel like it's maybe not connecting so much
because they're introducing all kinds of elements
yet the movies and shows are not really going out
of their ways other than like doctor strange
connecting to wanda's story in wanda vision
a lot of the movies are not seemingly referencing
the events of prior installments in phase four and
going because of this thing that happened in phase
four now this is happening in our movie you even
had to have kevin feige at the premiere of doctor
strange too say because of the events of loki what
loki and silvi did that allowed the events of
spider-man no way home to happen and the events
of doctor strange multiverse of madness to happen
but the movies don't say that while the movies are
not maybe going out of their ways to to really
point and go see look look hey remember this
guy i think it's because on the multiverse
is something so vast and dense and complex
and they're bringing so much from the comics
into the fray because what did we get with loki
we had timelines and then you have multiverse and
then doctor strange too introduced what incursion
events and then with eternals you have gods you
know even godlier gods yeah you have these cosmic
entities right now what i think marvel's doing i
think they are having a through line the common
belief is that they're building up to avengers
secret war i could see that happening i could
see that being like the big ultimate cataclysmic
event i believe the comic run my god i should
have really done a refresher on this i read the
comics before one division came out and my comic
retention memory in detail is not the strongest so
correct me on anything i get wrong here because it
was like the secret wars in the 80s and then there
was like 2015 but the one before the 2015 run was
i believe it's a comic called out of time i think
it's called out of time and i think that's what
they're building to first which has like a new
group of illuminati members from earth616 there's
incursions happening and they're trying to figure
out how to save their universe while dealing
with incursions in the multiverse that eventually
segues in to secret wars i feel like that's where
we're going first as maybe like the next avengers
5 movie with everything that's been set up in
place what i think is cool what the mcu has been
doing is they've been allowing more often than
not sometimes you get things like a black widow
i don't really feel like the unique voice of the
director in that movie phase one through three had
a lot of different genres it did feel more like
marvel's directing this movie than it is like
the own director's voice and i feel like you hear
like that more often close y'all's eternals are
like close movies sam raimi's multiverse madness
felt like sam raimi behind the camera the shows
really feel like the director's medium way more
than just marvel committee granted marvel's hands
i think what they're doing is something that'll
kind of creep up on us in a way that may not
be so obvious is that by the time we get that
crossover event what you're seeing is a battle
for a lot of different authorities happening
right now you have like everything with the
tva introduced there you have kang who's had
his own multiversal war and now king's back and
he's probably gonna want to dominate earth 616.
situations with incursions set up by clia at the
end of multiverse of madness you have eternals the
gods you know like this is something where i think
we are building two secret wars but i feel like by
the time we get there that's when we're gonna see
how it's all connected as opposed to telling you
beforehand how it's all connected if that makes
sense yeah that's a really good point i feel
like they still want to be able to surprise us and
it's only gotten harder and two i feel like if you
think back on the original phases of marvel we now
have the benefit of 2020 hindsight in that that
was a three-phase build up to thanos so i don't
expect the same kind of cataclysmic culmination
out of phase four necessarily and yeah i mean we
have had phase four introduce a lot of gods and a
lot of new characters and a lot of committees that
try to oversee but not necessarily interrupt what
is happening on earth or whatever realm is subject
to the story the pandemic probably did figure in
koi said something that's always stuck in my
mind of like i think they had a five or ten year
plan that got interrupted by the pandemic and now
they're figuring out probably a new 10-year plan
but i still feel like yeah it's a first phase
of what's to come even though it's phase four
even though it's continuing out of what we know
already they're still doing a lot of setup and
there's still you know i think a lateral motion
that can happen there and yeah i think a lot of us
are a little taken aback and i feel like this is
probably due to the pandemic that there aren't as
many direct acknowledgments and direct crossovers
especially with things like loki and they've had
to remix these films so how it appears to me is
more like yeah they might have had to kind of
hamper some of that huge interconnectivity given
the uncertainty of just the world right now but at
the same time yeah we have already speculation
of secret wars coming down the pike and i feel
like they are well aware of that too and they
probably want to make us you know focus on a
whole array of other things before getting there
and so yeah while phase 4 doesn't necessarily
feel like it has a direct end point it's trying
to get to it has had a lot of very consistent
themes and character dynamics that it's been
establishing thus far at least and i think it'll
be interesting to see how marvel changes how its
phases work and operate moving forward because the
first three phases are good to start with they're
kind of crisp and contained you know they're five
or six movies maybe a little bit more than that
but a culminating in some kind of avengers thing
i feel like we could see a change to that moving
forward because they also have to make us not get
too used to like okay there will be five or six
movies and then the avengers there'll be five or
six movies in the avengers so yeah i'm curious to
see how they uh emboldened the interconnectivity
of the shows and films moving forward they did
stress that at you know the the unveiling of a
lot of these shows and it hasn't played out in
such a connected way as they suggested so i feel
like that's something that they want to do i feel
like they just haven't been able to do it just yet
well i think it is all connected we just don't see
it as clearly yet you know like the shang chi post
credit scene had captain marvel in it and the
marvel's is probably gonna factor in heavily to
everything we're talking about right now and you
know and then we got secret invasion coming up
because i think there's so much information like
the comics enough are difficult to keep up with
that for bringing this to movies you have to kind
of take this one step at a time so that way we can
understand these definitions better so that way
when things start running into chaos we kind of
understand what the chaos is as opposed to there's
a whole bunch of mumbo-jumbo words being thrown
around i don't quite get the differences between
incursions timelines and multiverses i think that
the first three phases were so much about saving
the universe and i think what we're building to
is saving the multiverse you know we got king
the conqueror coming back for ant-man quantum
mania i think the obvious thing a lot of people
are speculating on is that kang would be the big
multiversal baddie especially the way loki set the
events and considering who kang is but if we are
really headed down this path i am curious to know
if dr doom will actually be the big baddie when it
comes to the multiversal threat it would be cool
if like we think we're getting kang to be the big
baddie but we're really building to is doctor
doom who has like a mastery on the two things
that are being introduced heavily right now in
the mcu which is magic and science fiction crap
cosmos like there's so much things that dr doom is
the master of and when it came to secret wars he
was the big baddie of it he ended up taking like
bits and pieces of the multiverse creating his own
world battle world i think is what it's called
that's where the big crossover event happened
which got a new future for marvel comics moving
forward after secret wars was a whole mix of
things so i think what they're doing right now
is getting a super acquainted to understanding
the rules and the definitions that way when the
rules are being broken we understand the stakes
and we could follow what the hell is going on
in this movie because because of the fact of how
crazy all this is going to be this is all going
to be nuts and it is all gonna be connected and
i think it's already connected they're just not
making it as obvious because it's not as simple
even if they borrow from secret wars i think
that's all it's gonna be i think they'll really
borrow from it civil war was very different in
the comics than it was in the movies the infinity
saga very different too you know they might be
borrowing like the the main idea but i think what
they're they're um streamlining some of it to make
it more digestible for the average audience member
i'm here to defend marvel i get that paycheck
you gotta marvel's gotta pay me my money that's
right they need they need your help don't hold out
hope guys just stop don't know it's all gonna make
sense it'll it'll connect you'll get your cameos
i promise all cameos are coming get your iron
man 2 level of inter crossover guys anyway what
do you guys think i'll talk with you guys soon